[Music]
in her ante and Mays home jing-mei
reluctantly takes her seat at the
eastern corner of the mahjong table at
the north south and west corners are her
auntie's longtime members of The Joy
Luck Club this group of immigrant
families comes together weekly to trade
gossip feast on wonton and sweet cha-cha
and play mah-jongg however the club's
founder jing-mei's mother su yen has
recently passed away at first jing-mei
struggles to fill her place at the table
but when her auntie's reveal a deeply
buried secret about soo Yeon's life
jing-mei realizes she still has a lot to
learn about her mother and herself in
Amy Tan's 1989 debut novel The Joy Luck
Club this gathering at the mahjong table
is the point of departure for a series
of interconnected vignettes the book
itself is loosely structured to imitate
the format of the Chinese game just as
mahjong is played over four rounds with
at least four hands each the book is
divided into four parts each with four
chapters alternately set in China or San
Francisco
each chapter narrates a single story
from one of the four matriarch of the
Joy Luck Club or their american-born
daughters these stories take the reader
through war zones and villages of rural
China and into modern marriages and
tense gatherings around the dinner table
they touch upon themes of survival and
loss love and the lack of it ambitions
and their unsatisfied reality in one
aunty Lang plots and escape from the
hostile family of her promised husband
ultimately leading to her arrival in
America in another their xu family's
all-american day at the beach turns dire
when Rose is overwhelmed by the
responsibilities her mother assigns to
her the resulting tragedy traumatizes
the family for years to come these tales
illustrate the common divides that can
form between generations and cultures
especially in immigrant families the
mothers have all experienced great
hardships during their lives in China
and they've worked tirelessly to give
their children better opportunities in
America but their daughters feel weighed
down by their
parents unfulfilled hopes and high
expectations jing-mei feels this
pressure as she plays mahjong with her
mother's friends she worries in me they
see their own daughters just as ignorant
just as unmindful of all the truths and
hopes they have brought to America time
and again the mother strived to remind
their daughters of their history and
heritage meanwhile their daughters
struggled to reconcile their mother's
perception of them with who they really
are
does my daughter know me some of the
stories ask why doesn't my mother
understand others respond in her
interrogation of these questions tan
speaks to anxieties that plagued many
immigrants who often feel both alienated
from their homeland and disconnected
from their adopted country but by
weaving the tales of these four mothers
and daughters together tan makes it
clear that jing-mei and her peers find
strength to tackle their present-day
problems through the values their
mothers passed on to them when the Joy
Luck Club was first published tan
expected minimal success but against her
predictions the book was a massive
critical and commercial achievement
today these characters still captivate
readers worldwide not only for the way
they speak to Chinese American and
immigrant experiences but also for
uncovering a deeper truth the need to be
seen and understood by the ones you love
but what happens when being honest with
those you love reveals a terrifying
truth watch the Chinese myth of the
white snake an epic tale of deception
courage and above all love
[Music]
Oh